the government is saying that it will
allow scientists to explore gene editing
to develop different strains of crops
which will produce higher yields and be
more resistant to climate change assam
to you first of all do you welcome the
open up of opening up of gene editing
would it be good for the planet do you
think
i do welcome this i think it's a great
opportunity actually which we can take
advantage of outside the eu to introduce
more innovation friendly policy i think
gene editing does have potential for
example to reduce the amount of carbon
intensive fertilizer that we use to grow
crops i think it also potentially uh
will enable us to grow higher yields on
existing land which means we can leave
more land for for nature and for carbon
sequestration so i think this is a win
for a win for the climate and it's only
the first step but i think there's more
to do the government's going to look at
the wider regulatory regime on gene
editing um but but i strongly welcome it
okay and dave what's your take i mean
george uses the environment secretary
has said it's a tool that could help us
tackle some of the biggest challenges
that we face around food security
are you in agreement with sam and george
eustis
well i think there are
some positives that come up with the
idea of using jumo crops um as sam's
mentioned the nutrition the more
resilience however i do think that we
need to recognize that there isn't
long-term evidence on how this affects
the environment and this could actually
be tinkering with nature and causing
larger issues than we already face um
there is lots of questions about
biodiversity i'm remembering that in
this you know environmental crisis that
we're facing climate is one part and
that's only one boundary out of the nine
that we have and biodiversity is there
as a very prominent second boundary and
there may be issues around biodiversity
with um following through some of these
scientific technologies
days the government is saying that foods
would only be allowed to be sold if they
were judged that they don't present a
health risk they don't mislead consumers
they don't have a lower nutritional
value does that give you some kind of
reassurance
sadly not really and i feel that the
government has a track record of putting
forward um profit before people's health
and we can see that with things like um
the canberra oil field or hs2 um or even
the silvertown tunnel
expansion so there is that kind of
question of can i truly trust this
current government um to uphold people's
well-being before profit and the answer
sadly is no sam
um i think this is quite a cautious move
from the government that all they're
doing is making the research and
development of these uh genetic
varieties of genetically engineered
varieties of crops easier and less
bureaucratic there are still going to be
strong regulatory processes around the
actual selling of these gene edited uh
crop varieties uh in in terms of you
know people's people's supermarket
shopping so you know i think the
government is right to take this step by
step and you know the weight of
scientific evidence i think you know the
the consultation responses they have
from from academics in particular does
show that people think there is no
additional risk from to biodiversity or
to human health from from this measure
because it is simply accelerating
processes that have naturally in nature
or indeed through traditional breeding
methods so it's not really introducing
foreign genetic material okay this
tradition with gm crops